c'est un sacré bond en avant pour la
société avions mon boussens le
constructeur aéronautique basé à belfort
vient de recevoir une aide de 800 mille
euros de l'état pour le lancement de son
projet zéphyr imaginé en 2018 il vise à
développer la toute première génération
d'avions hybride à hydrogène
c'est elle était effectivement un boost
très important pour nous ça nous permet
de passer la première étape de la
conception technique de la propulsion
hybride hydrogène c'est-à-dire un
démonstrateur au sol ça va nous
permettre de faire la conception de
cette structure est d'en réaliser une
première maquette sur bancs d'essais
destinés à la mise au point au sol
alérion mehal sion voilà les deux
prototypes hybrides d'imaginer par le
constructeur belfortain ils
fonctionneront de manière rechargeable à
l'aide d'une partie électrique et d'un
système à l'hydrogène
le tout sans aucune nuisance sonore ni
rejet d'éléments nocifs
notre idée c'est d'être les premiers sur
le marché erp est une solution pratique
c'est à dire utilisable avec de la
charge utile du rayon d'action et de la
vitesse à horizon 2025 pour notre
premier avion le biplace alérion et à
l'horizon 2027 pour le 6 place à lyon
qui la suivra imaginez le système de
propulsion hybride est une chose mais il
faut aussi dessiné et concevoir les deux
avions l'aspect structurel est donc tout
aussi important dans le travail
quotidien des ingénieurs on a deux fois
dans l'avion - on aura besoin d'une
d'une puissance de moteur élevé et donc
plus on pourra gagner en carburant moins
de conditions un peu tout ça quoi alors
pour optimiser la structure la phase de
process passe d'abord par l'élaboration
de maquette à échelle réduite
ça c'est un moule d'un
d'un éléments de fuselage de l'avion et
on va s'en servir pour mettre au point
notre procédé de fabrication de notre
visage voilà on commence sur une petite
pièce
pour faire des essais rapides et pour
par la suite pouvoir fabriquer une
grande pièce avec le même procès une
fois leur conception terminé les avions
mauboussin pourraient être assemblés sur
un nouveau site à belfort si tout se
déroule comme prévu la mise sur le
marché du premier modèle aura lieu en